[Applause]
[Music]
I I'm GNA get to your dance moves in a
minute star no we have been around each
other too many times for me not to know
that you were a dancer oh well yeah yes
yes but I don't tell people that oh I'm
sorry let's go ahead and bring up this
photo yep look at that ch yeah oh look
it out to play
Oh I had no idea wait Kelly that was 50
lbs ago whatever if you can measure Time
by weight accumulated wait were you
talking like that to the
dancer no no I was a performing member
of three different dance companies in my
day that's amazing in another day in a
different chapter of my life yes groovy
and you can Groove I like well no I
liked it there was nothing like dance
shape because you're strong you're
limber you're flexible yeah and graceful
and so totally just like me just like
just like me that's what I say you just
celebrated a birthday yes I'm an
official old crusty man whatever so two
weeks ago I turned 65 oh my incredible I
say it's a blessing not everybody I love
age because it's a blessing not
everybody gets that so here's the thing
here's the thing don't get old unless
you have wisdom to show for
it oh man
it's like the fortune cookie I get but
don't understand s so cool you how I'm
feeling that's how I'm feeling well we
knew that it was your birthday so we
have wine for you oh my gosh a little
bit of pean I know you like red wine you
like red wine so for your birthday this
is from our friends at duckor Vineyards
um and this is a 2021 Costa Brown P Noir
want I love P I'm all into Pino thank
you thank you wait but your favorite is
a burgundy right is well burgundies are
the red burgundies are mostly pinoir so
I'm all in oh I don't know that much
about okay what what what now you tell
me now it comes out girl okay I'm tell
going to go there and not go all the way
look I go I go to the wine tasting and
they're oh do you taste the oak totally
like I just tastes like something that's
going to get me to a good time you know
what I'm saying that can happen to yeah
yeah so to other than dancing um were
you always into science like when a kid
were like at birthdays did you ask for
space gifts I figure you did well I can
tell you so my earliest uh I was nine
when my parents took me to the Hayden
planetarium here in New York City I'd
never seen the night sky but well they
showed me the night sky in the
planetarium there were thousands of
stars this is beautiful but it's a hoax
because I've seen the night sky from the
Bronx it's like eight Stars this is not
the right night sky I would later of
course learn that that was the real
night sky to this day when I go to
mountaintops the greatest observing
sites in the world and I look up and I
say it's so beautiful it reminds me of
the Hayden
planetar no I'm telling you you at some
point no joke you have to come to my
Ranch in Montana it is the most
beautiful sky you you know the last time
you had Ranch and an eclipse went on
your property I didn't get a call from
you I know but that's because but I
didn't say oh I'm going to invite you
now I'm saying I'm inviting you so okay
we got this on Rec but I didn't know
that was going to happen in my defense
and then and but it was cool not to rub
it
in but no it's it's such a beautiful
thing Montana Big Sky oh my God and it
feels like you can touch the Stars
something I never felt in the Bronx yeah
yeah that's what that's what that was by
the way when um when I was dancing by
the way I was still studying
astrophysics and and and I had fellow
dancers who were making extra money
because I needed money because they
weren't paid much yeah and one of them
said why don't you come down with us
that they because they some of them
danced at a strip club like a guy strip
club with the women you have a picture
no
no ah no no no no I just want to like
clarify make it my birthday no let me
clarify that so I went and I I was cut
and flex I could do a full split so I
was but but but I went to just
investigate right I went data first I go
there data yeah yes so I'm I'm watching
them come out and they had ASB bestus
lined jock straps that had been ignited
with lighter fluid and they came out
dancing to Jerry Lee Lewis's song Great
Balls of
Fire now now now now let me just say let
me just say let me just say I'm
embarrassed that only in that moment
when I saw their genitals on fire did I
say maybe I should be a math
tutor maybe there's another way before
that but that's stupid I you're using
your dance skills I could totally tutor
math and it didn't occur to me to so I'm
going to be honest with you like I've
never been to a strip club not against
do your thing but I've never been to one
but like if I were to go to one I don't
think a lot of balls are being on fire
at a lot of them I think that was a very
specific strip club it was it was I I
I'm just saying at that point I had
other thoughts about how to earn money
you're like I'm gonna keep this junk
safe you have a new documentary I love
that Earth's Own it's Earth's Own well
we're proud of you I am from Earth
you're one of the good of humankind like
man yes but you have a new documentary
let's talk about it yeah yeah I'm I
served as script editor
an executive producer on a documentary
that explored anti-science thinking in
our culture and how that influence
people to not be vaccinated wait are you
talking about people like flat earthers
well that they would be come under the
broader category of anti- science think
oh you're doing it in a PC way I see
okay okay right right no there there's a
there's a whole camps of people who
think something is true that is not and
science the methods and tools of science
are exquisitely tuned to
establish and enable and Empower you to
distinguish what is true when you
otherwise think it's not or what is not
true when you otherwise think it is and
so this is what science does that find
objective truths in the world that's
what led to this quote I say it again
the good thing about science is that
it's true whether or not you believe in
it yeah okay now the moving
Frontier can can be ratty okay but once
a a result is established and verified
Yeah by other labs and things then hey
we've discovered a new objective truth
about the world and you can't debate
that and and by the way so I was brought
on as script consultant and then
elevated to executive producer by the
the the director writer and producer
Scott Hamilton Kennedy who's A
documentarian in fact he's in the
audience right now where is it Scott go
right here
Scott he's done other films just trying
to explore just how we get truth out
there where people think it's not and
Abol this is an important place to be
especially today we have these Waring
factions when everyone a trusted person
that people yeah entirely yeah because
it's hard sometimes media how they
navigate us like it's like it can be
hard to know where to put your trust so
this past week it it premiered in New
York and it's going to premere in Los
Angeles at the end of November and so if
I can give the website shot in the arm
movie.com shot in the arm shot in the
arm that's the the book right is what
there's the book oh no the book is
something else I've a lot of different
things sorry look at you okay go what's
the book what's the book talk about the
book talk about the book so so six weeks
ago I published a book uh co-authored uh
called I to infinity and beyond oh to
infinity and beyond yes I love it Buzz
Lightyear okay oh yeah and it's it's
co-published with National Geographic so
it's a beautiful book cuz they don't
make ugly books that's not how they
and so it's an exploration of what it to
stand flat footed on earth look up and
just wonder how would you ever Ascend
now Icarus tried it with his wax wings
they melted the bo died okay but what's
your next thought is it I will never try
that again or maybe I should make wings
out of a different material next time
yeah and so this book is an homage to
all the people who kept
ascending to every next point that was
previously at infinity and then you go
beyond it so we put people on the moon
but our robotic emissaries have been to
Mars Jupiter Saturn and Beyond to
contemplate the origin of the cosmos
itself it's very smart it's very clever
yeah that's what that's it keeps you
going it keeps you in it little biscuits
along the way yeah little biscuits okay
all right let's get to the best and
worst part of space so every time Neil
is here he tells me something terrifying
about the universe that I end up
Googling me I don't come in I know cuz I
want to know I'm a prepper okay I like
to be prepared so it's something we
call have to Dan
space
what oh my
God oh my God I didn't know that was
[Music]
coming all right so you're welcome freak
me out right sorry you know what In
fairness you're about to scare the hell
out of all of us so go ahead what's one
thing oh okay you want to know ways we
might die delivered by the universe okay
so we just brought back a sample from an
asteroid called benu This is an asteroid
whose orbit crosses Earth's orbit okay
any there it goes and any asteroid that
crosses Earth orbit will one day collide
with Earth it's just a matter of when
asteroid benu it will cross Earth's
orbit and we think it could hit us with
a one in about 3,000 probability in
2182 that's not far okay so and no it's
not far and and the as is about the size
of the Empire State Building so no it
won't render us extinct but wherever it
hit would be really bad okay so so but
160 years that's plenty of time to find
Bruce Willis
exactly no get him up there no there's
plenty of time to figure out there's no
way to protect us from that no
no list no we we have no there are no
why don't you shoot at it no there's no
plans right now to deflect anything we
are sitting ducks and you know the
dinosaurs had they had a space program
they'd still be
here today we're going to do something
we've never done with Neil a mini
planetarium slideshow with photos from
the James web telescope so explain to
everybody What that particular T quickly
yeah it's like the follow on to the
Hubble and it's that much more capable
it's specifically designed and tuned to
view infrared light okay why because
Galaxy being born in the early Universe
give off ultraviolet light and since
then the expansion of the universe has
stretched the ultraviolet light to
become infrared so we are going to be
observing the birth of galaxy es after
the universe has already altered the
light that comes from them and that
infrared also allows you to peer into
gas clouds to see the birth of stars oh
yeah oh these P I can't wait for
everybody to see these pictures okay
let's move over to our studio
planetarium here we go here we
go all
right so we're in we're in
[Applause]
space we're you know what we're always
children
so let's see the first image here we go
first image what is this TN oh okay this
is the central part of What's called the
Eagle Nebula okay you don't see the
eagle because it's way bigger than this
this is in the middle and by some it's
been called the pillars of God o Because
deep with inside those are gas clouds
punching through Interstellar space and
deep within them stars are being
born look at that Barbara stri Dan in
the sky okay next image let's see next
do it we're still floating okay so this
I love this one looks like an eye my
people we name things like we call them
this is called The Ring Nebula because
it's fuzzy and it's in the shape of a
ring if you look at the very center like
right here there's a star okay that is
the star that released these gases in
its as death throws so that is the
remnant of a star like the sun yeah that
has given up The Ghost and when it is
has done so the outer lays of gas Rise
Up from the surface and continue to
expand in the shape of a ring leaving
bare the core of the hot star that is
now dead the Ring Nebula I just think
it's beautiful this is my favorite one
it's beautiful all right let's do
another one next image here we go bring
them on what's next oh okay are we this
is okay this is another we Marvel
Superheroes right now okay so now watch
so watch so this this
is another star that has died oh in fact
it has died in recorded history this is
called The Crab Nebula this is a star
that exploded and this is the guts the
remnants of that explosion that has been
expanding ever since it was first
observed this was first observed by the
Chinese on July 4th 1054 ad what yes we
have it on record when the star exploded
so none of that was there on July 3rd on
July 4th the guts now the reason why
it's guts because these high mass stars
manufacture heavy elements like nitrogen
oxygen silicon iron these are the
elements that are made that comprise
life so what happens they just going
flow off so they fly off and then they
enrich other gas clouds that for the
next generation of stars circle of life
so yes so they'll have planets and with
the right ingredients some of them might
even have life I love it one more we
have one more one more guys go come oh
Jupiter there we go okay so again
Jupiter in infrared light but they move
it over to visible light so you can see
it wait put the whole thing back there
where put where is it at I like you're
still dancing thank you right so so we
got this spot here so in regular light
this would be red and we call it
Jupiter's red spot that's the official
name of it cuz that's how we roll okay
I'm just saying very specific but what
what I want you to notice is that on the
North Pole and the South Pole it's
there's glow it's like teal I like an
orange it's glowing this is Aurora on
Jupiter Jupiter has magnetic fields just
the way Earth does and particles come
from the Sun and they see that at
magnetic field and they split they
collide with the atmosphere render it a
glow and you get the Aurora Borealis the
Northern Lights have you seen the
Northern Lights here uh they're they're
not interesting my wife is I'm sorry I'm
I'm sorry I this is me floating away in
okay no no everybody can have a Mont
Ranch I want to see them I want to see
you get them in Montana we ain't getting
it here in New York City I know I've
never seen them though yeah yeah so if
you to far south it's just a kind of a
glow but the farther north you get to
see the colors and the dance of Lights
as the particles through Earth's
atmosphere as a dancer you should love
it so so all I'm saying is that when you
compare planets we say Jupiter's really
different from us well in some ways it's
not it has Aurora just just the way we
do and this is a way to compare and
contrast objects in the universe you can
list what's different you can list
what's the same and by the way this spot
okay just for context here this spot is
about five times the size of Earth what
so Jupiter has storms that are larger
than Earth Earth would be just a blemish
on the surface of Jupiter Jupiter is
badass in the solar system that's sorry
can I say no
you that's so cool oh yeah thank you so
much I
love so cool all right so Neil's new
book is called to infinity and beyond
and his new documentary is a shot in the
arm be sure to check them both
[Music]
[Applause]
out thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home